hello and a very warm welcome to the
latest edition of talking Germany to
show where we do just that now my guest
today is quite simply one of the most
successful film actors here in Germany
and areas in person
Mario Adolphe thank you very very much
for joining us today here on talking
Germany it's a great pleasure for me now
Mario Adolphe has been in acting for six
decades in his early days he was best
known for his portrayal of bad guys of
villains some of them absolutely
remarkable roles later he appeared in a
whole series of what you might call art
house movies the most outstanding of
which was probably the oscar-winning
adaptation of the Gunter Grass novel the
tin drum now I should add that Mario
Adolf is also a very accomplished
entertainer author and conversationalist
so it's great to have him here on the
show thank you Mario DAF I looked on a
on a well-known internet site and I saw
that they listed that you have played in
208 movies yeah I'm sure you can't
remember all of them but the first
question is the first question I have
for you can you remember the first time
you ever went to the movies as a boy you
can tell me yes I think that was in the
30s
hmm around thirty six or seven I was
bored but six or seven years old I think
and it was a film a movie with Spencer
Tracy uh-huh and and I forgot the title
it is where you played the sailor who
who died a very famous famous film it
was called
I knew the title it is it the title is I
think the name of the boy uh-huh yes and
it made a big impression on you yes I
cried you cry as if it was such a sad
story at the end and I always for that I
love it it's Spencer Tracy and if I
master yeah do you have any Idol
you know is somebody who you really
admire
I'm always said yes by the most admired
actor in my life
mm-hmm was Spencer Tracy wonderful and
tell me this what was the difference
between going to the movies back then
and going to the movies now is it the
same thing or is it a different world
well certainly this is not I don't
remember very much no more oh I know I
remember where the cinema was Howard it
was like you know and I remember even
the chairs that the clapping of you know
of the of the wooden chairs and so it
was and you had to have tickets number
tickets with you but these seat numbers
yeah so it's not today you go to a
cinema I know and you have to find a
place this was at the time even after
the war I remember that you have to you
know tickets you with the seats for our
english-speaking audience I think the
film that most people would think of
first when they think of you and your
work is the tin drum the adaptation of
the Gunter Grass novel which won the
Oscar that movie was about the period
that you're talking about the period of
your childhood yeah
when you were making that movie was did
that bring up memories for you of that
period oh yes I think it was quite
important you know I mean naturally I
knew more about life at the time about
the atmosphere about fear fear yes and
about hunger strong strong emotions and
feelings fear and hunger the multitool
most important emotion genes did you
know hunger yourself in that cell yes oh
yes this is something in my life I've
been too privileged I've never known
hunger in that sense yes anger was a
very important thing
during the war or even more after the
war because during the war you know it
was rather organized what you got you
know to to live on you know but after
the world there was nothing and there
you really felt hunger and the most
funny thing even is that the most hunger
I'll ever experienced was when I studied
in Switzerland this was the interesting
thing because when you went after the
war to somebody you a friend or a family
they always asked you you hungry
have you eaten take an egg take a big
piece of bread and so forth you know
this would not happen to you in
Switzerland because they didn't know it
was not their fault because they didn't
have this kind of solidarity yeah that's
a fascinating story I didn't think this
is where we're going to begin today I
didn't think that hunger and fear would
be where we were going to watch the
bombing you know he's robbing ok we'll
talk a little bit more about that very
shortly you've heard your first
impressions there from Mario Adolphe
here is more Mario a Dorf a star who
says he's had a lot of luck in life few
actors can look back on a career as long
and successful as his
an exhibition on his life at berlin's
Academy of the Arts in 2012 testified to
that with material from his private
archive which he donated to the Academy
photographs and documents related to
over 200 roles in movies television and
onstage to top it off the actor is also
a successful book author and entertainer
Aadhaar played in Hollywood westerns and
in spaghetti westerns
Maui adopts path to stardom didn't seem
inevitable he was born out of wedlock in
Zurich in 1930 his mother moved with him
to Mayan and Germany's Eiffel region and
worked day and night as a seamstress to
survive financial straits forced her to
place him in an orphanage for a few
years only once in his life did he meet
his father a married surgeon from
southern Italy mariano if lived in rome
for almost 40 years trying to be more
Italian than the Italians and seeking a
homeland and an identity but Italy
wasn't the perfect match he hoped for in
2004 he moved away from Rome Monique Fey
has been his life partner for more than
40 years and his wife since 1985 the
couple spend most of their time in Paris
and Munich the actor runs into fans
wherever he travels and today he's our
guest on talking Germany Mario a dog
Mario daf we were talking about your
childhood we were talking about a really
tough time you would talk about hunger
and fear in during your childhood when
was the first moment when you thought I
want to be an actor how long I didn't
know that it would be an actor or become
an icon very early as some actors do
mm-hmm
they were young they already played and
didn't staged plays and in high school
and so yeah I never did I never had I
already know that I realized that all
that we learn in school was not very
good during the war after the war so I'm
you have to go
University to to do something I didn't
know what actually might only know I
wanted to know more you know and then I
got in touch with the with the student
the theatre group and then I started
first as a designer you know for
costumes in sets and so forth and and
then I I wonder one day I saw one of my
colleagues and he was so really bad that
our that that I can do - and then I
proposed you know to give me a small
part
a year later I played a big part of
ready and then I went to Zurich
University and I still didn't think
about you know become an actor but I got
in touch with the professional theatre
in Zurich and there I started you know
as an extra and as and as an assistant
director and then I went to Munich and
there I wanted to go he still Duke
University and finish my studies there
but then looking for a room I passed by
the acting school the Academy Munich and
I just you know curious oh that's too
late for this year though come back next
year but as you hear come on fill out
this form in the form and I did and I
went to back to my hometown and I was
working at the time you do earn money on
construction and ice and I saw my mother
you know with a letter in the hand and
said and I climbed down it she said what
is this he said what said this is a
letter that you have to go to the
Academy you know as a hearing yes
why didn't you tell me and I said I
forgot I had forgot oh I had forgotten
mm-hmm and I went there and they took me
okay yeah and then you you began acting
on stage you were in the theatre
initially and then you went into cinema
and I'd like to talk to you about we had
it in the report just there yeah the
movie I'm trying to remember the year
now 1957 I think 90s when the devil came
it was yoga start was the devil strikes
at night okay oh just a few okay and
that movie is a that is a remarkable
movie tell us a little bit about it well
at the time this was a very popular and
very famous series and on a magazine
mm-hmm you know something like a popular
magazine in Munich yes and and there was
this character a real character
Bruno utica who had killed about over
maybe a wounded people as a 66kg was a
serial sex killer in between 1924 and 44
yeah and at first i iearn
when I was offered the part I met Robert
seared market the director and it was
very very funny story that a friend of
mine scriptwriter he said to you I want
you to get you to know Robert see it not
he is preparing this film and is it all
to do this film said yes when and when
when and at the theater I came late for
the appointment because the very night I
had played in the Rainmaker they wrote
the funny part of Jimmy when I had
strapped him a muscle you'd pull the
muscle I pulled a muscle yes and I and I
walked in you know with a walking stick
in there and and he said and he said
ah sounds mobizen can even look hit me
said you know and I said no he said no
this is not evil more no more listen now
this is not good this is evil he said I
need to pulled office his glasses and he
looked at me with his big eyes you know
and and then it wasn't and I turned
around and and then he said what have
you done to your leg I said I pulled a
muscle and what I didn't know he was
what we could what we call a healer he
was somebody had the kind of obsession
you know that he could heal people you
know he was a dog like a doctor and he
took me to his hotel and and he said
pants down and so what is this now and
and he took these sprays that you hope
today we use for football and Sam and so
kinda and he did this and they said
these doctors they don't know anything
and he said and know what still hurts
said no I lied and then we came back to
the et delayed through the bar we were
way off with all his friends and so and
then he said that is my devil look at
him how mean he merely can look and in
the movie you did look very very mean
indeed yes it was it was remember that
they didn't want to play the part in and
I in my contract I written in roman that
in the next following picture of the
same company I had to play a sympathetic
positive card okay
and let's move forward in your career
later into the 70s 80s where you played
in art house movies frankish learned off
ryan Averna fast builder that was a very
different world yes
what did that mean to you well for me it
was when I lived in Italy at the time
for many years and then all the old
directors you know died or were very old
and then the German would be called the
new German cinema was born
you know and many actors known actors
they refused to work with these young
directors who didn't know anything their
opinion and I said no I have to work
with them that's the future and and it
was there and I said Here I am I'm ready
to work with you mm-hmm
and you played in some remarkable movies
learned off movies that the Fassbender
was all a great movie yet then and I
want you to tell me this story you were
you were close to working for Francis
Ford Coppola in the Godfather one of my
favorite movies
tell me the story it's a remarkable
story well yes I met a quarry in Rome
and he asked me if I had read the script
they did the book Mario Puzo who those
pieces yeah I said yes and I've even
read the shooting script no nobody knows
that I said well I've written it I've
read it yeah said oh who did it give to
you who did it give to you I said I
won't tell did you find any part in the
novel or in the script that you would
like to play I said yes and which part
is it Sonny corioli the oldest son of
Marlon Brando oh oh oh no way that we
have already cast James Caan so James
Caan he's a red hair he's not he's not
the son of Marlon Brando look at me I'm
the son of Marlon Brando I said well
he's already cast and I must say he has
the right accent accents you can learn I
hope is there any other part in the book
there are many parts many characters in
the book any other party would like to
play I said no well don't that was that
was that no regrets
I suppose the first question is - was
that role written specifically for you
which one the nino here in the film yes
really anybody because we were on the
burger on another film the actress
leading actress died and in within three
weeks the director the woman director
Lola
Randall she wrote a story like that and
she said she said would you like to to
play the to work with me again I said
yes would you do this part I Fritton I
happen and I said yes without having
really read it you know because I knew
her situation she was in a shock you
know after the death of this actress and
then she did she had to do something and
she just ended within three weeks she
wrote this script and we did it in 13
days and one of the important ideas one
of the important premises in the film is
that the two characters you and the
young woman can ask each other any
question that you want yeah if somebody
were to ask you from your long life and
you have lived life to the full what
have you learnt about life what would
you say what I learned about life yeah
it's a big question isn't it just go on
just go on yes look forward not bad or
not too much bad okay and what have you
learnt about yourself
very little is that good or bad to have
learned very little well we say you're
needed a certain age
no he's becoming really rising German
you know why's why it's wisdom yeah and
I don't think that I'm wise in that
movie you were working with Fritzi
Holland
we haven't she's a remarkable young
German what was that like it is
wonderful
yeah just you you soso a life in Seoul
so and
reelin and and then pleasant you know
she's and and funny he's remarkable
actress I really liked her very very
much
I've seen her on the stage playing
theater here in Berlin excellent once
how good a German movies these days a
German movies doing well when you can
look back on a long career you can
compare where are we now I've seen many
ups and downs now and sometimes even too
much of the optimism you know that they
said well now the German feeling made it
to be able to become international and I
always said calm down hmm
stay where you are don't be too
optimistic about it sometimes there are
good certainly a generation in use and
regeneration comes that they make better
films as they used to do before and so
the film business but it's not a very
great business Germany in Germany nor
the film and it cannot be so German
terms are always limited you know to to
Germany mostly so it's interesting that
we talked about the tin drum and some of
your other films have been really very
much about German history the films in
Germany that are very successful outside
Germany are also about German history
like aftermath with it the film about
Hitler downfall I mean to the film the
lives of others goodbye Lenin all these
movies have been made is that because
Germans think too much about the history
as that because they're the only films
they can sell outside Germany I don't
know if they think about that I don't
know
I don't I don't know I don't I don't
think so that they think about the
International they yes they think about
international success now but I think
there is not a very precise
way you know - mmm there's no formula
yes there's no form you know formula we
have to do this to become successful or
so they're all very personal individual
filmmakers and they make their films and
and I think that's good so that's good
for in for Germany for France for Italy
and so forth but and very rarely for the
international market okay dokay
Mariota if you don't just you're not
just an actor and an entertainer you
also write yeah you write books yeah
why do you write well I I'm not a writer
you know I'm you're a very good writer
I'm no I've always considered myself
that's a discrete storyteller you know
and I just wrote you know my stories
mostly real stories or some invented as
well so but if not I'm not really a
writer I'm a storyteller okay let's stay
on books now and have a look at a man
who wrote one of the most influential
books in history the name of the book is
des capital and the author Karl Marx who
were not until that long ago was viewed
by many people as a as was a largely
discredited political philosopher but
the global financial crisis has put Marx
firmly back on the agenda Karl Marx his
monument in Berlin is impossible to
overlook but does the philosopher
economists and social theorists still
have anything to say to us today
Carmack's Karl Marx doesn't really mean
anything to me I don't know him I think
we've gotten over that to be honest he's
got something to do with communism right
Karl Marx communism communism that
doesn't ring a bell for me I don't think
one needs to read Karl Marx today
because everything connected with this
went wrong so is Karl Marx outmoded for
all time no says Terry Eagleton a
British Marxist literary theorist and
critic he wishes more people realized
how timely Marx is once people don't
read Marx they see him they know
something of a stereotype of his work
you know it's like somebody who's
suddenly saying what was the name of
that guy Freud oh the man who believed
everything was sex yeah it is literally
as crude and vulgar and reductive as
that when in the economic crisis the
capitalists themselves are talking about
capitalism again says Eagleton then they
have a problem and if Marx was anything
then a critic of capitalism that's the
subject of Eagleton's book why Marx was
right but I think that's part of what
Marx gives us today a recognition that
we have a system that it has certain
internal conflicts that it's never able
fully to master or resolve those
conflicts and therefore that we need to
look in other directions but those who
lived in communist East Germany feel
they've seen enough of that other
direction
they acted as if they'd already created
an ideal world and it wasn't ideal you
know just look at East Germany there
have been lots of attempts but it always
failed in practice so why doesn't it
work because people are very egoistic
the unpredictable human factor
nonetheless Marx provides a precise
analysis of the system that is now in
crisis his recommendations weren't very
concrete but you can read that analysis
in the seventy eight thousand pages of
the complete works of Marx and angles
perhaps will come to the same conclusion
as Terry Eagleton
Oh Karl Marx yeah
that's capital yeah do you have a copy
of dust capital on your bedside
you do not man or maybe not at the time
of the bedside copy yeah yes you read
the book from cover to cover
certainly not definitely not very few
books I have read to the end but you are
very interested in Carmack's yes but
what actually what I was interested in
in telling his story a very short and
interesting story about the Karl Marx
last year his life you know which was in
62 when he made it a trip to Algiers he
made a trip to Algiers yeah I didn't
know that it's very interesting because
at the time it was very sick already you
know we had to pre-register already
called yeah yeah and so annual set you
have to you know to write the second
part of capital so you have to write and
go but this year the South of France is
spared weather so go to Algiers but it's
good weather it was actually just the
opposite it was good good weather in
Montecarlo and it's and not analogous so
but it's what was quite an interesting
personal story and experience especially
with the his encounter with the Arabs
with the Arab philosophy and politics
and for instance that they do not have
private property property yeah only
communion mmm-hmm Robert II now this was
very interesting and so I think marks at
the time was more interested in in this
world new world for him he never
travelled actually you know he only knew
Germany this is where suppose he went
it's an order you know North Africa I
didn't know this
time yeah and he and he spoke Russian
and he was never mean in Russia he spoke
Spanish never been in Spain but he knew
you pages by heart the Cervantes in all
these in order to beat the French
authors and Russian all of us you know
he was a big brain you had it before a
fantastic intelligent man you really was
and you would like to have played this
raw would have liked this very you've
got the beard yeah well I have made even
tests you know with the photos you read
photos and we could have done could have
done all right let's say but there's
little chance you know that it has
because it could be done because there's
still some resentment you know the the
people are interested is there oh that's
interesting but then you say you do with
and to give money and pay money for it
mm-hmm but it could still happen because
now Karl Marx is suddenly much more
relevant people suddenly says we saw on
the report yes yes absolutely and it's a
pity that we don't do it but they still
they will do television we do this kind
of movies about his life is his entire
life you know and exactly young man and
so forth which are not doing anymore
have you ever been to a demonstration in
your life no no no do you do you go on
you're gonna say no I don't believe very
much in German stress you know the one
you know of the whole eco the people
without a job you know their demonstrate
you know unemployed in unemployment
demo yeah okay and there's a man talking
to some of these SS look I have worked
for you
here's my card call me come to see me I
have work for you and this man says why
me there are so many you know I don't
know okay okay don't believe imagine
demo demonstrations I ask you this you
you've we're gonna talk about where you
come from
you've lived in lots of different parts
of Europe now is because a lot of people
when we talk about Karl Marx they think
about sort of utopia's is Europe for you
a utopia is Europe where you live rather
than one individual country well I I
always considered myself European hmm
because I like was born in Switzerland
no I grew up in Germany and lived for
many many 40 years over philia in Italy
and I always thought that I was your
peon not as a German as much as your
German or Italian or whatever you know
and or French so I always thought from
the beginning that the idea of Europe
was a very good idea okay Komatsu we've
just been talking about was born in the
city of Trier it's located close to
Germany's border with Luxembourg and
France in the state of rheinland-pfalz
in Germany's wes's just up the road from
where Mario Adolphe grew up the name of
the region is the Eiffel region as we
find out now in our next report it is a
lovely part of the world water in all
its forms is typical of the Eiffel
region in western Germany
a common geographical feature here are
flat crater lakes called Mars they
reveal the origin of the region's
mountains volcanoes the greatest
concentration of Mars is around the town
of down they formed almost 20,000 years
ago among the eiffel's architectural
treasures is else castle
the castles proud owners are the fun and
sooo else family they don't live in the
castle but they look after it and keep
it open to the public
the Benedictine abbey maria laughs in
the eastern eiffel is the most
impressive of the many cloisters in this
catholic region it was founded in 1093
on the shore of the her lake halfway
between maria la and eltz castle is
mayan with almost 19,000 residents it is
one of the region's biggest towns
and is also called the Gateway to the
Eiffel about 25 kilometers west of here
the Eiffel doesn't seem quite so
tranquil in season the Nurburgring a
Formula one racetrack is not restricted
to professional drivers anyone with a
license can go for a drive on it
including a notorious Nordschleife ax
the oldest part of the track which is
also known as the Green Hell but for the
most part the Eifel is serene the
population density is only 115 people
per square kilometer which is low for
Germany by comparison Berlin has almost
4,000 people in the same area
it was very interesting of that on that
report looking at Mayan yes just explain
to us white why this town is so
important for you still I mean you've
lived all over the world but Mayan is
your home is himat yes that's high mud
for me and then your only one you
actually don't have to and I look for my
other home in Italy and I didn't really
find it in Calabria that's likely it was
interesting but I feel very strongly and
I'd always say you're high Mert is there
where you grow up where you hear the
first children's songs where you have
your first love where you have your
first school days and so forth you know
that's that's what what stays I mean you
it was a very tough time for you yes
your child you were in an orphanage for
a number of years yes and it was not it
was a difficult place to be
you know well yes it was not easy but I
I don't know that I had really a trauma
and I really they really suffered I
don't think I didn't know my mother kept
me away from all problems you know
anyway your mother was very very very
important for you yeah she was a very
strong woman he wrote this book of you
dedicated this book to her night that's
a that's a it's a wonderful thing to do
but I still have to ask you why why did
you write this book for your mother it's
a good question I'm because I know she
wouldn't have liked it you know uh-huh
yes because well that was her life and
she was she didn't want to that anybody
knew about her when I wrote my first
book she she didn't want me to tell
anything about her to mention her and
when she died before she died she said I
just don't want to I want to disappear
I don't want to exist no grave no no
just you know spreading to the see that
should that's what you wanted you know
she wanted to not to be there nobody
should know about her I said that was
her life you know so there had to be
problem you know writing about her but
still I must ask the quiet why why did
you write it what was the important what
was the feeling you've had an itch
somewhere something with inside you says
you must write it I thought it was I
think in a way that she was not right
about herself you know that you weren't
that she was nothing that you didn't
want to be anything you know I won't the
tiny nor to treat her not always in a
very very nice way you know but very
seriously and and to give her the place
she really deserved that's a great thing
to do yeah you said
somewhere I I don't regret growing up
without a father and then you said
something else which I thought was very
interesting and I'm going to read it to
you now you would like to have had
somebody who said who would show you the
way it would say do this do that don't
waste your time with this right you
would like to have had a mentor yes yes
and maybe that I did not see the normal
role of a father as that the normal
father the fathers are you were not like
that you know but and this kind of
father I did not miss of them just of
the father who was there you know as the
you know this is somebody to tell you
what what not to do yeah I wanted maybe
somebody whose tells you what to do
which book you you you write you you
read and and and so forth that that's
what I thought
and I that's what only I realized later
that has thought that I did not have
somebody who said who took me by the
hand as you say you know go there read
this go there see this learn this you
know you were left to yourself very much
so yes my mother worked she had to work
and she and there was not much place for
education and no for I didn't I always
had to do it myself he said if you run
yeah ok it's ok then you go on high
school and so forth and if not you
become a butcher
Mario odd if I think you have done a
very very good job with what you were
given that's my feeling
ok we're gonna move on to the the quiz
at the end of the show I give you two
alternatives you give me an answer
yeah
oh I can hear the music who do you find
more interesting the good guys or the
bad guys bad guys wonderful we've solved
that problem now that's all we have time
for I'm afraid with Mario Arda what a
life and what a guest if you'd like to
find out more then do read my blog on
the talking Germany website and if
you've enjoyed the show as much as I
have then come back next week until then
bye bye entries
you
you